[Music]
hey what's up everybody yeah we're going
to do this show before we um
get ready to [ __ ] get out of here and
go see that cronenberg movie tonight
yeah we're going to go see the david
croninberg tonight because but it's not
i don't know why but they're only doing
one showing a day and it's like at 10
p.m so right oh well what are you gonna
be back late tonight pookie's gonna be
like where the [ __ ] did they go
where are my meat sticks yeah you'll
have to give her something before so
last night uh finally got around to um
renting uh the batman yeah we were
actually going to watch ghostbusters
after life
but i mean you can buy it but you can't
rent it for whatever reason so then we
saw the batman and tom's like oh i
wanted to see that so we decided to rent
that instead yeah
what did you think of it thomas
i thought it was good
yeah i liked that as well because i was
thinking what is it i don't what is it
about i like about this movie and what
is it i don't like about them it was
kind of like doing i was kind of looking
at it from both sides
um
and
what they what they did here is they
everything they did in this they kind of
had to do
because there's so much batman out there
they had to do something that was
different
yeah so they because to give it its own
identity so you're not ripping off other
batman [ __ ] series
um
so what they what they went with it's
almost kind of like a noir
noir
detective
flick yeah and i liked that angle and
from what i know like i'm not real real
up on the comics
but from some other like comments that i
saw about it a lot of people that are
real into the comics said that this
movie most closely approximated what it
was like reading the comics particularly
the ones that came out like in the 90s
and 90s like the long halloween and
stuff like that yeah yeah a lot of
people said this it was very similar in
tone to that it's um
what i did like about it is that he was
soft-spoken he wasn't like the and where
is he you know like the last one he
wasn't he wasn't all like that he was
real soft-spoken he's not even very big
he's um kind of cut but he's not in real
[ __ ] outstanding physical condition
he's just kind of a slender guy
um
which sometimes i'm like well hold on he
just [ __ ] beat [ __ ] eight dude's
asses and did all this [ __ ] and that
guy's not all that strong [ __ ] and
that's not really how a fight goes down
when you're fighting guys they just dog
pile on you and you're at the bottom
it's like you're attacked by a football
team you know
but i'm going like well it is batman you
know what i mean they're [ __ ] and he
does have like the technology yeah
this suit's pretty decent
um
but it's not real gadget gadgety it's
just kind of a bulletproof suit
um
it had some stuff like darts i don't
know what that was for i didn't see him
ever use them uh
he had a pretty cool car he had a good
motorcycle look at a bmw
motorcycle uh the car was looked like
something that had an engine in the
front in the back and a [ __ ] rocket
on it and
uh pretty neat but it didn't go too much
into the bat cave it just showed it it
was just uh just a dark [ __ ] place
underneath something somewhere they
don't really
they don't really he's got a mansion
somewhere but they don't really
give you any scale about where this is
in relation to the city it's
it's just vague maybe that was good to
keep it kind of vague
that way they could expand on that later
yeah i don't think they ever showed
wayne manor like from the outside did
they no like they showed him like
upstairs in the like the dining room or
whatever like one time generic [ __ ]
castle looking place yeah
and then um
he had zoe kravitz in there is [ __ ]
selena kyle and uh i liked her selena
kyle i thought she was good
um
then again you know it gets back to
[ __ ] you look at she looked great in
those in all the outfits they put her in
[ __ ] real hot
they put her in the damn catwoman outfit
it's not quite a catwoman outfit it
doesn't have a cat mask but it's just a
it kind of has little ears on it but
it's just a little stocking pulled
overhead this is kind of like
batman's first mission
so it's like his character isn't fully
solidified really
you know
towards the end it is but because they
say he's been batmanning for two years
right doing the vigilante stuff yeah so
he hasn't really got the hang of it he's
more in like revenge and like just
beating the [ __ ] out of people yeah
so um
zoey is probably [ __ ]
411 maybe 410 she probably weighs 90
pounds she is a tiny person
[Laughter]
she was beating up some [ __ ] 220
pound dudes it's not realistic
but then you got to go well it is a
comic book movie yeah um
although she does do some cool [ __ ]
that's kind of
they can see they try to put a little
bit of realism on this so it's it's not
totally crazy certain things that they
do it's far-fetched but
like she jumps off buildings and how the
hell did she do that well she could they
showed her doing kind of like parkour
early on
going down the damn fire escapes and
[ __ ] like a gymnast like a gymnast
and [ __ ] and then landing on her feet
and little bitty heels and [ __ ]
um
and then uh they showed batman doing
things like [ __ ] jumping off of
buildings and he started he's he had one
of those [ __ ]
like the [ __ ] flying squirrel outfits
i don't know what you call those things
and he's [ __ ] catching air and trying
to pull out of the dive and his little
[ __ ] parachute comes out the back to
slow his ass down and he [ __ ] it up and
hits the ground it was like
like under an overpass yeah i did
actually like that because he was like
hey cool it's working oh [ __ ] you know
at least they're trying to give you a
sense of like that [ __ ] goes wrong so
there's stakes yeah because he when he
hits the ground [ __ ] it's kind of
like wiping out on a [ __ ] bike if
you've ever done that you're [ __ ] up
he's limping away and [ __ ] because he
was probably going 70 when he hit
um
i know exactly what that's like
couldn't get out of bed next morning
[ __ ] jenny [ __ ] had to take me to
the bathroom i'm pissing out blood
couldn't get my shirt off she had to
feed me set a big mac on his chest and
pushed it toward his mouth
you're okay the first day it's the next
day you wake up and you're just looking
like like you've been hat like you've
been [ __ ] hammered that was something
else you could even put his own pants on
couldn't put my pants on or not just
couldn't even move
but then like uh
the st the the writing is good the story
is good the the villain's good in it the
re the riddler
he does some cool she's just like a
serial killer
yeah he's like a real smart
dude and he's just used the internet and
he has a [ __ ] internet following and
you don't find out until the very end
all these dudes are gonna meet up with
him
it's pretty cool dude the place
commissioner gordon is the same dude
that played [ __ ] felix lighter in
this past [ __ ] um the james bond
james bond moves i love that character
he was a [ __ ] bad he was the best
felix of all times
because at least he had long speaking
lines and did [ __ ]
and he goes way back he wasn't he was in
shaft too i think he was in the uh the
first thing he might have been in the
shaft yeah so he's showing it shows up
in detective and [ __ ] secret agent
movies and superhero movies now so
uh he made a real good gordon he's like
the only
he's the only [ __ ] stand-up cop on
the whole force everybody else is pretty
much [ __ ] corrupt and i like too like
i said because batman is still
considered a vigilante by pretty much
everybody and i kind of like that gordon
is kind of the only one that's sort of
like sticking by his side like you know
what i mean like batman like shows up at
some crime scene like because gordon
said it was okay and everybody else is
like the [ __ ] is this guy doing yeah
now the dude that plays
the batman himself okay as a character
the way he got it set up i liked it
it was different than the other batman's
but it was still batman
i could read into that i could say that
from the comic books you know like the
dark knight [ __ ] that we used to read in
the [ __ ] late 80s early 90s that's
probably that's pretty close to kind of
how i imagined him and i was going you
know what that's a lot like the crow
and he is a lot like the crow this movie
looks a lot like i mean you know the
crow was going back and like you know
was like quite kind of a noir film yeah
crow one not the other crows crow one
that's what i'm talking about it's like
crow one
he's conor goth
oh yeah kinda
and
like before you know they'd had some of
the old cheesy batman he'd put the
[ __ ] mask on
and then around his eye sockets it was
black you know what i mean [ __ ] they
didn't show the putting on makeup for
[ __ ]
uh procedure like oh well he's a real
man he don't put on makeup yeah well
[ __ ] in the goth world you gonna put
on that [ __ ] makeup to get this
[ __ ] play so i like the fact that
they actually show yeah he wears makeup
you know what's funny he's eye sockets i
was watching uh chris stuckman's review
of this movie and that was another
detail that he particularly liked oh he
did he's like i liked that yeah he's
like in every other batman movie you
know he takes off his cowl and he
doesn't have makeup on he's like even
though you can kind of see it like under
the mask yeah but he's like i like that
they were that committed to like detail
and realism that he had
when he takes the cow off he still has
black makeup like all around yeah his
eye sockets are black yeah because they
would be that's the only way you can get
that look sure now [ __ ] the the now
the the old television series from the
60s he
he he wasn't wearing any black makeup
and that that didn't look too good yeah
it looks a lot better
when the eye sockets are blackened out
so you just see eyes piercing out of
like a black [ __ ] yeah face you know
what i mean with a little [ __ ] white
[ __ ] bottom jaw you know just eyes it
looks good and the only way to get that
is to darken your eye sockets well you
could do that now and you could do that
with the crow crow was wearing makeup
yeah you know he had they showed him
putting his makeup on before he's
[ __ ] these dudes up yeah so i kind of
like makeup is for everybody it's not
for it's not just for well he's in a
costume
he's in a costume
you know what i mean and all those other
actors are wearing makeup you just don't
they just make it they're just trying to
make it like they don't have that they
don't have makeup so yeah but [ __ ] no
batman be wearing that's what used to
make me laugh like back in the 80s like
when my grandpa used to say like he'd
see like like boy george or something
like that like look they're like wearing
all that makeup i'm like dude the
newscasters are wearing makeup they're
just trying to make it look like they're
not every time you see a broadway play
those [ __ ] wear makeup if oh if
you're there on tv they got makeup on
yeah with me
but yeah that's that's just funny but
yeah i did kind of like i mean obviously
it's a superhero movie so it's not gonna
be like completely realistic but i did
like the attention to detail like that
where i was trying to make it like as
grounded as possible yeah and i know
that some of the other batman movies
have done that too probably more than
any other superheroes because batman
isn't supernatural like
all of his stuff comes from
you know his money and he makes all
these gadgets and [ __ ] like that but
now as far as uh selena kyle and stuff
you know what i mean my boy my boy
[ __ ] um he didn't uh
he didn't really like it he was going
that you know i don't know if i like zoe
kravitz as
as selena kyle
and everybody's got their favorite
catwoman you know my two favorite really
the prettiest catwoman was julie newmar
okay she's pretty but she wasn't my
favorite one my favorite one was
um again um
[ __ ] what's her name the uh
the one from the tim verton catwoman uh
[ __ ]
well halle berry was captain no no no no
no no michelle pfeiffer
yeah fair ones michelle pfeiffer well i
always liked michelle yeah she did a
good cat woman and earth the kit earth
the kit from tele from the television
series i love earthquakes
yeah right and for me those two that was
well those were the best those were kind
of like the orig my original favorites
but you kind of combine those two zoe
kravitz is kind of a combination of
those two characters you know the main
[ __ ] in the way they look so
yeah she was i thought she was good she
kind of she reminded me of of michelle
pfeiffer in some ways and then she
reminded me of eartha kids in in certain
ways
again i liked that they made her kind of
like
more of a grounded character yeah i mean
she just she works in a club she works
in the nightclub and it's like she
initially gets involved with batman
because her best friend and roommate
yeah goes missing yeah and she suspects
that the mob guys that are at the club
that she works at like had something to
do with it yeah she gets involved in
that turns out her dad is a gangster
yeah it's falcone it's her it's her dad
yeah and
the dude that plays falcone and this one
is [ __ ] i like that i like that kid
john
turturrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrroooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo
y yo you yeah i love him
he's a great actor and you don't know
whether or not he's lying or telling the
truth or what the story is and you know
he's kind of a complicated character
he's bad but he's capable of good things
and he's capable of at least telling
some good stories or good lies that you
might believe in you don't know if it's
true or not though what he's saying
that's just what's kind of like the way
life is i guess
but um
i thought it was a good noir movie
it is a detective movie that has a lot
of superhero elements in it
um
it's as good as the bet i think it's as
good as like
other goods batman's and much better
than shitty batman like batman and robin
is much better than that well i mean
most movies yeah the batman
let's be honest
[Laughter]
some of the tim burton
actually
you know the tim burton batman the first
one was pretty good and the second one
was mostly good there was some [ __ ] in
that i didn't really like you know what
i mean in term burton's second one got
started to get a little too goofy
uh i'm glad that it didn't do any
goofiness
in this one yeah this is an absolutely
not goofy movie at all i mean it's very
grim yeah it's gritty yeah kind of like
a kind of like joker i thought it might
have been the same universe but the
technology doesn't matter doesn't quite
match up yeah this one seemed like it
was modern day yeah they had modern
technology well and at the end when
hopefully you guys have seen it i mean
you know what i mean well i'm just going
to say like at the end with the riddler
yeah and you see the joker yeah that's
the joker right like in the next and he
looked young yeah he was young so it's
kind of like a different universe now i
think yeah and i think that they're what
they plan to do with this and i'm sure
they're going to do it now because this
made a [ __ ] ton of money um is that this
is going to be a trilogy obviously
because everything is now and i think
they're doing a couple spin-off series
on hbo max as well yeah okay um that's
going to be set in this same universe
because like i said they this is another
i mean it's not like we necessarily
needed another batman movie because
there's been so many and there's been so
many like reboots and stuff but
i mean people keep going to see them and
they make
billions of dollars so obviously they're
going to keep making them if people keep
coming to see them and this was actually
a really good one and like i said they
they deliberately like went in a
different direction with it and went
more like in a noir detective kind of
thing zach was saying that um you know
that it had been inspired by chinatown
and stuff like that yeah it's much more
that kind of thing like i said there's
nothing funny in it it's not goofy that
it was kind of inspired by chinatown
yeah okay yeah um
there's nothing goofy in it there's
nothing silly in it it's just it's very
very serious some people might say it's
too serious depending um but yeah it is
very
grim and it's just kind of like
it's almost it almost
is like a david fincher movie i want to
say it's almost like a david fincher
type
like zodiac or something like that yeah
um
i really liked the look of this was
great i really liked the score it's
weird but i was into it um i liked that
the way they used that nirvana song i
thought that was cool i heard that song
in a long time actually and um i didn't
even realize because a couple of you
guys pointed it out that colin farrell
was playing the penguin i didn't even
[ __ ] recognize him i didn't recognize
him until i looked at the cast later i'm
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i would never
have recognized him like if he hadn't
said but the guy that directed this and
co-wrote it as well was the same guy
that directed uh cloverfield which was a
really good monster movie and he did the
american reboot of let me in like the
vampire movie let the right one in which
was actually like uh quite good and he
did a couple of the newer planet of the
apes movies as well all right so there's
a couple things i didn't like about this
movie
it was long
yeah slightly long i mean longer it was
what three hours three hours right yeah
it could have been a little bit shorter
another thing is is that there were some
scenes and i'm looking at batman's face
he doesn't have his mask on especially
especially when he's sitting next to
something sitting next to alfred when
alfred is in the [ __ ] hospital in bed
and i'm looking at that face and i start
getting this uncanny valley
feeling i go man that is not a human
face that dude is not there that's cg
i don't know that is kind of what he
looks like though that couldn't have
been i just started to get that creepy
you're looking at a corpse feel going
that that is that is not real that is cg
i mean it's it's really good cg
or they did some kind of cg overlay on
his face or something there's some of
those shots i'm going like that no that
is not a living human being that's
[ __ ] an image i just got that feeling
you know i couldn't believe you couldn't
see it
i mean i see what you're talking about
but i mean i've seen robert patton said
in other movies like he was in the
lighthouse you know that right yeah and
he was in well he was in those terrible
times no he looks no i no i'm saying
that's him but there were some times
when you show him
the skin texture and the eyes and just
the expression i'm going like that is
not that's not a real person that's cg
and when he would talk the way the mouth
would
would move it just you get that uncanny
valley
i think
i think he wasn't in that scene i think
they
had a stand-in and they did they cgi'd
his face over
that in that particular scene
and there was another scene for a few
seconds they showed him while he was in
the in the uh he was doing something in
the it wasn't through the whole movie it
was just a couple scenes i saw it
i don't know i wonder i mean i guess
it's a possibility because i think i
heard
that this movie kept because i think
robert pattinson got coveted at some
point so maybe they had to do some
reshoots and he wasn't around to do it
yeah i think so or something i think the
director guy there was some [ __ ] that
just did not look right i think i think
i remember hearing that yeah so i don't
so i don't know i don't know if that's
just
because of the lighting i'm not really
sure
i'm pretty sure with cg
and in that especially the hospital
scene and there was another scene in the
uh in in the bat cave
where he looked over his shoulder he did
something and i go no human doesn't move
that way
it looked too much like a
like a cartoon image you know what i
mean like yeah like like a video game
yeah i wonder if it was i wonder why
they did it in those particular just
real good with [ __ ] body language and
facial expressions and it's
i've never had a uh i've never had a
computer image ever fool me
i don't know why
i did i mean the thing about this movie
though i really really like it's similar
in tone to the joker i guess that's why
you were kind of saying that because the
joker was also like real gritty and kind
of grim and stuff similar tone to the
joker a bigger scale more special
effects a lot more action in it um
yeah less a character study yeah because
the joker was more of a character study
this one is more like like i said like a
detective
story like a serial killer right it ends
up ends up like a batman movie you know
what i mean with the [ __ ] big fights
with a bunch of dudes and you know
trying to [ __ ] flood the city and
[ __ ] you know what i mean blowing
[ __ ] up blowing [ __ ] up and so it ends
like a superhero movie just that most of
it is like a detective story which i
like that i like that yeah well that's
closer to the to to the old series that
they had yeah i mean
finding clues
asking people trying to figure out what
the riddler's talking about
um
missing clues and having to go back and
get it you know that kind of [ __ ] and uh
also all the
the uh the supporting characters were
basically involved in organized crime so
then dealing with them is kind of like a
gangster movies
yeah because there was a lot of i mean
the i will say like the plot's kind of
convoluted but i didn't really find it
all that hard to follow i did think the
movie was slightly long but i think
that's probably my only like major
criticism it could have been a little
bit shorter but other than that i
thought it was really good and actually
visually it was really really nice to
look at i really really liked
like the first shots like when all those
um
when all those thugs when they're like
beating up that guy in the in the subway
station and like there's like shadows
and you don't know you just hear like
the footsteps like coming for a really
long time and then batman like very
slowly like comes out of the darkness i
thought that was like really really cool
yeah in the in the last big series you
know gotham had that look it just looked
like a [ __ ] gothic version of new
york you know
not this one this one it looks like
blade runner from harrison ford's blade
rudder it looks like that
raining
yeah it seems like it's dark and raining
like all the time yeah
a bunch of signs everywhere and it
looked like it looks like la
la from [ __ ] blade runner even though
i'm pretty sure they shot this in
chicago and i think they shot some of it
in the uk as well yeah but yeah that one
scene in particular where all the cops
are like closing in on the riddler and
he's sitting in that diner yeah it kind
of looks like it kind of looks like
blade runner but it also kind of looks
like that edward hopper yeah too but um
but yeah so it looks like that but yeah
it is very kind of like blade runnery
yeah it is very dark
uh the whole thing is pretty dark but
i don't know i just really liked the
look of it like you said it kind of
reminded me of of the crow in a lot of
ways like the look of it i really loved
that one
chase and i think this was in the
trailer like where they did the chase
scene and then like the the
batmobile like comes out of the fire and
then like the guy is like watching it
from upside down and then he sees like
just the shadow of batman like coming
out of the [ __ ] fire yeah it's very
much like blade runner and
you know the the the visual styling is
like old blade runner and [ __ ] the uh
in the crow the uh the movie's goth it's
goth it is it's got this one yeah
batman's a goth batman yeah he's even
got emo hair emo hair
that's like something that god dude it's
just kind of like floppy yeah
like floppy over one eye yeah and he's
very brooding yeah like i don't think he
smiles like one single time and selena
selena selena when she's not in her cat
burglar outfit she's just looks like
some chick from a [ __ ] goth club
flight a fish fetish girl yeah she's got
a big old boots and yeah big boots she
has some nice wigs and wow yeah wigs and
[ __ ] corsets and stuff and a lot of
pvc she's just you know like a fetish
chick
so yeah it's goth it's a goth bat man
is it uh as good as the last series it's
i'd say it's different it's it's a
different town
yeah it's hard to compare them because
it's really not it's coming at it from a
different angle yeah you know which you
know that's fine it has potential to be
as good as the other ones but like i
said the tone's gonna be a little bit
different
uh so far i think i think it's on track
it's on track it's got to be different
you cannot re do what you did before so
there's really no other place to go
and still have it batman i mean because
yeah they've done pretty i mean they've
done goofy ass batman yeah they've done
you know they've done more gritty batman
but i don't know this is like i said
this is kind of the first time they did
detective batman i don't know they've
done it like a little bit before but
almost tone is almost similar to the old
spawn too and it's visually kind of like
spawn also
gritty dark
yeah
you know
yeah i liked it yeah i liked it as well
yeah zach said the cinematographer for
this won the oscar for dune this year
actually
and a bunch of people are thinking he
might win again for this too yeah um i
wouldn't be surprised if he won for this
um it's it's a nice looking movie i
really really like a lot of the uh i
don't know there's the fight scenes just
i don't know i just i just like the
whole aesthetic of it as so you know
there's some people bitching and moaning
about it you know but well there's
always there's always you're always
going to get that
um but uh
no i disagree it's good there's nothing
else they could have done
you cannot redo the old [ __ ] you have to
[ __ ] go it's just a new path and they
just went kind of crow
yeah blade runner which like i said fair
enough it's not like they just pulled
that out their ass that's kind of what
they are kind of what it was and i mean
uh you know matt reeves he actually used
like i said some of the comics like from
the late 80s and early 90s like the long
halloween or uh year one and stuff like
that like he kind of matched those all
together yeah so he did get the story
from there it's kind of like a loose
adaptation i guess yeah and you can't
have like a [ __ ] huge [ __ ] reuted
out
[ __ ] batman anymore because that was
done already especially in the animated
versions some of those animated ones are
really good you know yeah mascara
fantastic yeah that's really mask the
fantasy i mean a lot of people think
that's like the best batman in any
medium 55 year old roided out [ __ ]
batman oh man my [ __ ] back you know
like
but that was also a good one yeah so
everything's been done and this is just
um
we're going to do we're you know this
batman's more kind of like you know
humphrey bogart mcgoth
kind of a
what's his name sam spade kind of a yeah
and you get the sense that he is that he
hasn't really like that he hasn't really
come into the character yet right he's
still kind of new to this whole
vigilante thing right right he's a
vigilante kind of like sam spade
kind of character uh
and
but of his time and place and uh
he's not he's young so he's still kind
of learning it
kind of like uh kind of like uh
james bond casino royale you know what i
mean his first mission it's kind of like
that
yeah i i approve it's good
it's good let's just see where it goes
but yeah we'll see what the because i'm
sure they're going to go ahead and make
it i'll give this i give this
episode two thumbs up let's see
let's see if uh let's see if the
follow-up is is as good it should be
i don't see why they could they can't
back off of this you have to go down
that direction yeah this is it has to be
like this
danny rowling said i haven't seen the
ben affleck batman's yet but not in a
hurry too either yeah i think initially
he was supposed to be doing this one but
then like [ __ ] happened and he didn't
end up doing it i don't think i've seen
i've seen him the batman versus superman
right it's good he's he's in did i see
that i think he's in it he's not bad
he's pretty good it's just uh
man those are cgi fests you know what i
mean that's that's going kind of [ __ ]
kind of the way like the marvel
doctor strange goes where just
everything is just [ __ ] cg you know
and you're blowing up the whole world
and they're staying he he's all right
explosion happened it knocked buildings
up but he but batman made it because
he's got armored suit on
it's just like come on
but it's it's just it's a different kind
of entertainment yeah you know this one
is a lot more grounded in realism
um
kind of like
that very first
well
i want to say grounded in [ __ ]
realism
kind of like batman begins there it was
khan or realistic either like some
things were kind of plausible
people can't really jump that far and
they can't really [ __ ] there is
certain [ __ ] that you know i mean it's
not physics doesn't really work that way
when you fall from that height you get
hurt doesn't matter what you do there's
all
it does violate that but it just has a
grittiness to it it's trying to be
like a 70s detective movie
that has a dude with gadgets that could
do some [ __ ] but his gadgets aren't real
far out he does the [ __ ]
[ __ ] bat grappling hook thing which
those don't work that those can't happen
mythbusters [ __ ] tried like hell to
get something like that to work
they showed you the problem they were
disappointed yeah they showed you the
problems with things like that the
things like that can't work or they'd be
everywhere
um
his little [ __ ]
boomerang or batarang he pulled it off
his chest but he just did it to cut a
wire he didn't i don't think he ever
threw it
yeah i don't think he did either and
then the only other thing he had he had
those contact lenses that had like
cameras in them yeah and [ __ ] uh it's
got like google
type [ __ ] where it id's you
puts your [ __ ] yeah like face
recognition yeah facial recognition
and it also had like a [ __ ] light
magnification or thermal mixed in with
it too
and uh he put him on catwoman and sent
her out on a mission he could see what
she was seeing and they could talk
together or talk to each other it was a
pretty cool trick
um
thing that was kind of weird is that him
and catwoman kind of fell in to fell in
together pretty quick
felt a little bit unnaturally too
fast i mean you know those are both
pretty hot people and that probably
would happen
uh but it just didn't seem like there
was any tension in the beginning next
thing you know he's flirting with her
just right off the bat but then again
he's not a cop he's a vigilante so he
can kind of do what he wants
and uh but he was getting involved
pretty early with a with a girl he knew
was it was a criminal she was [ __ ]
breaking and entering and stealing [ __ ]
maybe he justified he's like well i'm
kind of a criminal too yeah it's not a
good deal yeah and she seems kind of
like a nice person otherwise right other
than like breaking into she was breaking
into [ __ ] that was supposed to save her
friend
yeah i mean when he caught her like
breaking into the safe she knew that she
was breaking in there not i mean she did
steal money later on i'm not saying that
but um she was breaking in there to
steal to get the passport back like her
friend's passport because she knew that
that guy had taken it so she couldn't
leave
so she was her heart was in the right
place you know what i mean well like i
said that's kind of how they ended up
hooking up but she was looking for her
best for it was her roommate actually
and like her best friend had disappeared
and she knew that the mom had something
to do with it so they kind of like
started working together yeah i get what
you're saying but like honestly i think
like i said the only criticism i have is
it was maybe it's like slightly too long
but
other than that i thought it was like
really good yeah nothing wrong with it i
like nothing wrong with that at all yeah
um all right so
let's see are we um are we done yeah we
gotta start getting ready for tonight
yeah we're gonna go this evening and see
the new david cronenberg movie crimes of
the future matter of fact i need to
start we need to get the tickets now
yeah we'll do that as soon as we get off
of here we'll go get the the seats and
then it shouldn't be too crazy it's
monday night i don't think anybody's
gonna go monday night at 10 p.m there's
no telling with these people man to see
if anybody's gonna see it so that should
be the movie that we're talking about
tomorrow unless something untoward
happens so thanks for coming by and
hanging out with us and talking about
the batman today we will see you guys
again tomorrow evening